Let's take a moment to think about janitors.
Dirty,
stinky,
backbreaking work,
low pay,
low class,
low self esteem.
At least that's the image that many people have about this underpaid,
underappreciated segment of society.
But what are the origins of the word janitor of words?
Etymology as a history of its origin and usage.
Not to be confused with entomology,
the study of ents and insects,
the word gender traces its roots back to the Latin word,
young wa the work for door.
And that combined with the agenda of suffix tour gives us our modern word
janitor.
But what is an agenda of subjects and agenda of suffix is a suffix such as er,
oh are Ian or ist added to the end of a verb or now that changes it into a new
noun and essentially adds the meaning of someone or something that does whatever
the original work describes to work,
to exert oneself physically or mentally to do,
make or accomplish something becomes worker.
Someone who works piano.
A musical instrument becomes pianist,
someone who plays the piano.
So one of our Latin word for door.
When we take yen Wa Adore and act with the agenda of suffix tour,
we get a keeper of a door,
a guardian of a door.
Thus the original janitors had nothing to do with cleaning and everything to do
with the holding of keys and the keeping of doors.
The Romans who spoke Latin names one of their gods using the same group word for
door and Roman mythology,
demos with the god of beginnings,
endings and transitions,
and thus the god of doors and gateways because of his role as the guardian of
inferences and exits,
Jan is often pictured with two heads looking for ever into the past and the
future.
So yeah,
a pretty cool God.
It just for 10 years that we get the month of January,
the first month in the Julian and Gregorian calendar's and the first month of
the modern calendar name for Jim's.
Precisely because it is the beginning or infants of the year.
And if that's not enough,
one of Saturn's moons is named Ppar Gamma who says,
well,
so as we can see,
the word janitor was not at all a negative thing.
Saint Peter is even described in some texts as the janitor of heaven.
So why then have we come to look on the word janitor with disdain?
Precisely because language changes and in this case that were gender under went
to some men take change of meaning change through our process.
No Ms. Page,
aeration page,
or Richard is a process by which a word's meaning degrades or becomes more
negative.
For example,
the word Pagan,
which now refers to an uncivilized barbarous unchristian person,
has changed drastically from its original meaning of country dweller as
janitors,
who originally just acted as storekeepers and key holders naturally began to
take on the other aspects of a buildings maintenance.
The word acquired a more negative meaning.
Now,
it's hard to imagine a janitor without a toilet.
In our mental image,
though some may look down on janitors,
they certainly find themselves in good company among God's saints and Heavenly
bodies.
Until next time,
remember that although janitors might not hold the keys to the beginnings and
endings of time,
they do hold the keys to your office.